director of the institute chad
goldberger i'll just say a few words of
introduction and then we'll have the
main act
uh so we have been here for since 2013
and we are a center an institute for
collaboration with computer science and
adjoining fields and in particular the
topics of this uh workshop both
the lattice
part of it and the quantum part which is
the beginning which scott is going to
start
where two programs that started right at
the semester when the pandemic hit and
we left at uh sort of a week into march
and it was a wonderful program that
continued also online but what we
decided is to bring people back a this
summer for an extended reunion some five
weeks and this is the workshop that's
combining both the lattice and the
quantum
sort of group
and now we're extremely excited to have
a very interesting program
uh
is going to talk a little bit more about
the program i just wanted to say
something that really i think mesh will
reiterate and that is that there are
speakers that are not going to talk if
people are not fully masked you can
according to berkeley rules of be masked
or not
you know if you know in consideration of
the fact that we won't have those
speakers here and in general if you
couldn't ask we would appreciate we have
extra masks here um
in the um
there you go
thank you
thanks jeffy uh so
so yeah welcome uh
definitely everybody uh
uh to to this workshop it's um
uh i think that um
you know it was uh of course
extremely unfortunate that we we had to
interrupt our 2020 program halfway
through
but but they were it you know one can
always look on the bright side of things
and the
yeah what is that so so the the
the bright side is that
you know the two programs we had quantum
and lattices
already in 2020 they were you know there
were ties between the two people were
communicating across
but in 2020 i think there was there was
this sense uh
um you know on each side
that uh people really wanted to learn
about the about data they were very
curious they really needed you know they
knew that there was there were lots of
interesting things going on uh
in terms of uh that they needed to
understand about the other i think those
ties have become just so much deeper now
and so so in a sense you know
if we were to do it again
maybe we would not have uh wish for a
pandemic but we would have said the
ideal way to do this program is do half
a semester now and then do another half
semester two years later you know have
some sort of entanglement time
you know over time and uh so in that
sense you know there's a there's a
positive side to to it all anyway okay
so
so i think that that's that's also uh
something that's reflected in the
program of this uh for this workshop you
know it's it's a week-long workshop it's
uh with uh with a quantum side and a
lattice side and then there's a
you know i think there's definitely an
intersection
uh in in both halves and then there's a
very explicit intersection on wednesday
where you know which is which is really
uh uh you know deeply enlarged you know
the the two sides you know the crypto
side uh uh quantum sites so so i think
it should be a should be a very
interesting workshop now there's another
another aspect of it which uh
i should say that uh we we we have
really tried to emphasize in this
workshop
because um you know we've been so used
to working
online and in hybrid modes and this is
really a time for everybody to be
together and in person and so so we've
tried to keep this particular workshop
uh to be in person so that uh you know
of course uh the workshop is much more
than just the talks it's also all the
discussions you have around the talks
in person so so that's so
that's why we've tried to make it
make it absolutely
you know everybody impressive and so as
as shafi mentioned there you know
they're there there are uh
uh
speakers who um for
for reasons of having you know family
who are vulnerable
don't feel comfortable uh you know
speaking if if people are not masked and
i i can see everybody is so thank you
for doing that and and uh i don't think
we have to go to
fallback mode there
right so so we will try to keep
everything in person so so um
we are starting off with uh
with this morning session on quantum
algorithms and uh there are
there are two uh
uh fantastic talks uh
uh by uh scott aronson and mark zandry
so uh uh scott will uh will speak about
uh
uh you know so so there's uh this
subject which i think is is really very
uh both important and very interesting
which is which has to do with uh
uh quantum advantage uh you know uh
so we've had these developments starting
with uh google's uh
much publicized exp uh
experiment uh
um or
breakthrough on quantum supremacy and
then
various uh events after that uh trying
to show
either to increase the number of qubits
or to show that in fact though you know
uh you can have classical algorithms
that can catch up with uh with with uh
you know duplicate the same results
and uh these have been
i guess uh within within the last couple
of months there was there was another
breakthrough we you know uh
uh showing that um that classical
algorithms actually can do
rather well uh
on uh random circuit sampling so
um
uh scott's going to
help sort of help us understand all of
this so i'm really looking forward to it
scott
okay well uh thanks so much for it's
great to finally be participating in the
spring 2020 uh simon's program and uh
you know yeah it does feel like you know
years of progress have been made during
this program right so uh and and and um
thank you uh for the
introduction uh so uh so yeah so so um
um umash actually gave me this title and
the recent progress and quantum
advantage and then i had to think about
uh has there been recent progress in
quantum advantage and then i said you
know well definitely you know there's
been this breakthrough by yamakawa and
january but wait but but that's that's
that's the talk that's right after mine
so
so um so i'm gonna try to give a big you
know um um overview of a particular kind
of thing that uh that i really want okay
so this is that this talk is less to
sort of present uh results than to sort
of you know uh uh ask for something you
know as clearly as possible uh but by
the way i don't know if any of you have
been playing around with dolly the uh
you know ai image generator but you know
when i asked it like how much structure
do you need for huge quantum speed ups
uh
these were its answers i'm not sure i'm
not i'm not sure if there's any insight
in that or or or not okay but um
uh okay so my starting point is this you
know i i think of quantum speed up as
sort of a resource that you know we've
been handed that is uh in some ways
weirder than any science fiction writer
would have had the imagination to invent
you know i think if you were writing a
science fiction story you know if you
were going to have any kind of
computational superpower at all you
would just make the halting problem easy
or you would make np complete problems
easy by just you know some you know
magic you know try every possible answer
in parallel and uh you know and and and
to this day you know the the
misimpression persists that that is what
quantum computing is about okay but we
all know that uh it is uh something
stranger than that you know it is this
complexity class bqp which fits into the
classical complexity classes in a you
know somewhat weird way that we're still
trying to understand uh in detail okay
and um you know enough that uh we can do
certain specific problems that are uh
not
known believed to be in p
um
uh but uh uh uh but as far as we know
not the np complete problems okay and uh
and even among the np intermediate
problems maybe only some of them and not
others uh and yet you know maybe also
some problems that are not even in np
okay so
uh um
uh so what else uh uh what i would like
to call the the the hammer of hype you
know so like like when i you know every
uh uh every every few days um you know
like some reporter is you know doing
some quantum computing story and they're
asking me like you know can i explain
you know quantum computing in one minute
and i'm saying well you know can i can i
at least have five minutes right and you
know and the main points that i try to
get across are number one you know it is
not enough to just put quantum on top of
whatever you want to do and create a
superposition over all the answers uh
the only hope of getting a speed up
quantumly is to exploit interference
right is to exploit the way that
amplitudes being complex numbers are
different from probabilities
you have to uh somehow set things up so
that for each wrong answer the
contributions to its amplitude will
cancel each other out and for the right
answers the contributions to their
amplitudes will be in phase and we'll
and will add up okay and uh what's
non-trivial is that you have to do this
even though you yourself don't know in
advance which answer is the right one
right or else what would be the point
okay and of course you have to do it
faster than any classical algorithm
could have done the same thing okay and
this is the second central point uh
that uh uh you know it's not enough to
just come you know get a quantum speed
up compared to you know the first
brute force classical algorithm you
think of you know classical the
classical side gets the gets to fight
back right and um
you know and and this is not just like
sort of an intellectual point but it is
increasingly a practical point okay as
people are making concrete claims of
quantum advantage for you know
particular problems you know we we have
to
see you know whether they are actually
beating what can be done classically
okay so so now i'm gonna this is sort of
the most important slide in the whole
talk in fact you know i could if you get
nothing else i could probably just show
you this slide and then and then and
then stop okay but uh um
so so you know there are different con
you know so so so in this talk i'm going
to be interested first of all in
exponential speed ups that we can get
via a quantum computer of course not all
speed ups are exponential you know there
is the square root speed up of grover's
algorithm for example which is also
extremely interesting uh uh
um but uh uh um um you know the if if
you run the numbers you know the the the
uh the point where a a square root
grover speed up would actually give you
an advantage looks to be extremely far
in the future okay uh and this is
because you know you you know just to
you know you you to run grover's
algorithm you would need a fault
tolerant quantum computer right and so
then you're paying an overhead of
millions probably just to do that and
then you know the square root has to win
over that right and so then you know
your problem size might have to be in
the quadrillions or something before uh
before there's an advantage okay so so i
am interested in quantum speedups that
we can actually demonstrate you know in
the in the relatively near term okay so
you know of course you know there are
already experiments that are trying to
do this they're you know over the and
that's been a very exciting development
over the past two or three years these
uh sampling based quantum supremacy
experiments okay and we're and we're
going to talk about them okay but we're
also going to talk about how they have
some very significant drawbacks okay
that uh uh that we'd like to overcome
okay so so if we want an exponential
speed up from a quantum computer like
like what is it that we want from it and
the way i think about it is that sort of
there there are three main properties
that we that we want all at once okay no
okay i should say you know in in the
background you know whatever we're doing
should be efficiently doable by a
quantum computer right that is just you
know assume that that's just obvious
okay but now in addition to that okay
there are three
uh um um additional things okay the
first is uh what i'll call niskabal okay
so nisk was a a
term coined by john preschool uh five
years ago it stands for noisy
intermediate scale quantum okay
basically it means uh can we actually do
it uh uh with devices that we will
plausibly have let's say over the next
you know either today or in the next
five years uh without needing to build a
full
you know scalable fault tolerant quantum
computer okay so
um
you know this is not a formal
mathematical concept uh uh we should be
clear right it's sort of it's a sort of
thing or you know you you you you know
it when you see it right but uh
basically um
anything that involves sort of doing
cryptography you know on superpositions
of inputs is you know unfortunately
looks pretty far from what we can
implement today right what we can do
today is typically you know you can
either with um superconducting qubits
with um
trapped ions with photonics you can deal
with you know maybe on the order of a
hundred cubits you know 50 100 maybe
soon 200 okay
you can have some programmability in
them okay but you are you know your your
your um each two cubic gate that you
apply you know imagine that it has a a
fidelity of 99.5
you know today
you know maybe soon it will be 99.9
right and that's you know compared to
what things were when i you know i was a
student here in berkeley 20 years ago
right that's that's astoundingly good
okay but compared to what you need to do
fault tolerance that's still not there
right if if i have
if each gate i apply has 99.9 fidelity
then i can only apply a thousand gates
you know until there's a good chance of
an hour somewhere okay so so in the the
quantum supremacy experiments that
google and the ustc and china you know
have have done uh with with
superconducting qubits the the depth of
the circuit is about 20. okay so they do
you know 50 something qubits about 20
layers of gates okay these are the kinds
of numbers to think of right and so you
know what
what can you do with 50 100 qubits well
let's be generous let's say oh you know
100 layers of gates right well you could
apply a bunch of random gates okay and
you can measure and you can see what
comes out maybe you can do something
more interesting than that okay but
doing modular arithmetic
uh you know doing doing lattice
computations yeah it's probably not
going to happen okay so
you know until you can get fault
tolerance or you know at least some
amount of fault tolerance okay now uh
second thing that we want you know it's
kind of an obvious one we want to
actually beat a classical computer right
we want the whatever task we're doing to
be ex ideally exponentially harder for a
classical computer okay but this is you
know when you when you actually zoom in
uh you know this is this is um you know
this is often debatable right often you
know sometimes you you have a heuristic
algorithm you don't really know you know
what is the uh
you know what's the quantum versus
classical performance right uh uh uh you
know if if you squint you know maybe
there's an exponential speed up maybe
there isn't so you know we you know
because you know there are speed ups
that we can be more or less confident
about right and i would like to be as
confident as possible in the reality of
the speed up right uh you know i ideally
you know i would like to have like two
kinds of evidence together i would like
some formal hardness reduction you know
i would like some kind of formal
evidence that the problem is hard and
also i would like for the particular
instant size that we're looking at that
people have actually tried
experimentally to spoof it you know with
classical computers and you know and and
there remains a gap of in performance of
of of orders of magnitude
okay
so
okay now the third requirement uh is one
that has you know uh i think really come
to the fore over the past few years you
know with the quantum supremacy
experiments and this is you know we
would like to solve a problem where we
can actually recognize the correct
answer when we see one okay when when
the when that when the device produces
one okay uh so you know this could mean
uh that that you know i like like the
the the simplest way to achieve that is
by solving a problem that's in np you
know such as factoring or discrete log
okay but you know we can imagine broader
ways than that to get verifiability for
example you might achieve verifiability
via an interactive protocol you know
with the quantum computer playing the
part of the proofer okay and there's
been a lot of exciting recent progress
on on on on how to do that okay or you
know if you're doing a quantum
simulation we're gonna you know a
simulation of some chemical or some
material it might not be an np problem
but you might be able to verify the
answer by comparing against nature you
know by comparing against the chemical
itself okay so and and and validate the
result that way okay um
um but you know if the verification you
know itself takes exponential time then
that inherently limits you know the
scale at which we can be you know
demonstrating a quantum advantage right
so so okay so we're now in the very very
interesting uh situation in the field
that i would say that we know how to
achieve any two of these three
requirements
okay
so um so so you know what have the
quantum supremacy experiments of the
past couple of years uh done you know
they have gotten you know these two you
know they're they're you know we are
doing them in today in the nisk era and
you know well this i'm going to be
generous and you know you know i'm going
to say you know you know at least if if
you could do it with a good enough
fidelity then you know the the the
theoretical versions of these problems i
would say would solidly be you know
classical computing the actual
implementations that's much more of a
question okay so
um
um you know but but uh you know we you
know for you know uh uh simulating you
know you know you know let's say
you know solving the abstract boson
sampling or you know random circuit
sampling problems right you know we are
you know we're pretty confident that you
know that you will need exponential time
to do that now now anything you can do
in the nisk era right you know you have
to worry about noise in your device and
then you know you were you know so maybe
i should uh i should have uh sort of put
this a little bit you know like you know
trying to get into here but you know at
least at least uh i hope of going into
there
yeah this isn't a really important point
you know
you know
somebody could say you actually do not
know whether whether there's anything
you can do
open question given recent developments
yeah i would say that uh um so okay so
so so let's let's let's talk about the
situation right now so so you know there
have been classical spoofing attacks you
know that have been you know published
uh uh uh for you know both the random
circuit sampling and the boson sampling
i would say that you know that's that a
quantum advantage uh uh remains
depending on how you define it okay so i
would say you know uh uh the the um you
know like like like you know if you use
enough classical cores in parallel you
know and you use tensor network methods
then you know you can simulate what the
you know the you know these 53 qubit
experiments for example uh you know now
you know but but you are using you know
in some sense you know many many more
cycles than that than the quantum
computer is using right you're you know
and so you know like as as judged by
time you know you can achieve parity if
you'll spend enough money for coors you
know as judged by carbon footprint you
know the ironically the quantum computer
is winning you know just you know even
though it needs a dilution refrigerator
so
um
uh so you know but i would say that to
uh you know two two two two really you
know uh uh sort of merit this this this
being here you know what you know the
most important thing to do it would be
to do these experiments with a better
circuit fidelity you know so uh you know
if you can do if for example
if you could do you know the gates with
uh
99.9
you know fidelity instead of 99.5
percent then you can do a much higher
circuit depth when you do higher circuit
depth then the tensor network method
starts struggling a lot more right so
this is you know so so so quantum
supremacy is still like you know we are
still in the era where you know you
could have an argument back and forth
about it uh you know it's uh you know i
i think uh i sometimes use the analogy
of like you know kasparov and deep blue
in 1996. right it is you know uh um
uh you know i i you know but but uh it
seems to me that if you could you know
do these experiments you know with you
know a a a a higher fidelity than you
know even with 60 cubits or so you know
we would not know how to use tensor
network methods so i'm being generous
here and i'm i'm you know granting that
the experimentalists are going to
improve the hardware in that way in the
next in the next couple of years okay
but even
the the point i wanted to make was that
even then we still have an issue with
verifiability okay so i would say that
the the deeper issue the sort of deeper
problem with the sampling based quantum
supremacy experiments is that we are
inherently limited in how far we can
scale them okay
and
um and and and and the reason is that
the way that we verify these experiments
is just by doing a brute force classical
computation okay we do
a you know uh uh uh we know we we take
you know so so we will literally just
apply a random sequence of gates let's
say measure you know you that gives you
a sample from some distribution over n
bit strings so and then you keep doing
that over and over you get a bunch of
independent samples and then you have to
you know this is the hard part you have
to validate those samples somehow with
your classical computer okay and you
know the the only way that we know how
to do that is something like this linear
cross entropy benchmark you know that
google has used which which says you
just use your knowledge of the circuit
you calculate the probability uh uh you
know that each of the observed samples
would have been generated you know by uh
by a correct circuit and you sum them
all up
and you see whether that sum is sort of
interestingly large you know if if it's
if it's if it's a real you know if you
were if you if the quantum computer was
working right then you should be
likelier to observe the samples that
were predicted to have higher
probabilities right so you can do a
statistical test that way okay and you
know this is uh
you know as far as we you know you know
we we've given some theoretical evidence
that you know it should be hard to
spoof this you know meaning uh uh uh you
know there's that you know um um
um
i mean the the the current situation is
that there seems to be uh like like
uh there are there are polynomial time
classical algorithms that can get a uh
an advantage in this cross-entropy
benchmark that goes like one over
exponential in the depth right and this
uh the the depth of the circuit okay
this is recent work by boaz barack at
all okay uh uh
you know but uh but uh you know one over
exponential and the depth you know
that's you know if the depth is 20 or
let's be more optimistic if the depth is
50 or something then hopefully you know
the ex the experiment will be able to do
better than that right and then you know
we have we and then we have
something we have a score you know that
that is hard to spoof classically right
or plausibly hard to disprove
classically okay but
the biggest problem is that even to
calculate this score to validate the
outputs of these circuits we have to do
this exponential time classical
computation right and so so so that's
why you're inherently limited okay so
you know these experiments have only
gone up to you know as i said about 60
cubits okay but even if you were to
scale them to uh you know 200 cubits and
have it work perfectly you could never
prove it right because not even google
can do a two to the 200 computation okay
and and interestingly even if you had
another quantum computer you know we
still wouldn't know how to use that to
validate it okay because all the quantum
computer can do is sample right and
whereas what you need to do is estimate
the probability the ideal probabilities
for these specific samples
yes why why can't you get around the
verifiability by just
you know extrapolating from small
instances floating on a log scale and
trying to see how things well that that
that
that's exactly what people do right you
know you can just plot things on a log
scale and just say well i believe it's
going to extrapolate that that that that
that's exactly what is done right but
then you know then then gil collie has
his opening right and his ah well then
you know clearly the demon is you know
is going to come in at 70 cubits right
clearly you know this is all going to
stop working at the point beyond you
know you know just beyond where you've
tested it right so you know you would
like to be able to you know directly
refute that right
so
i mean yeah
there is i mean there's a serious issue
there right which is uh
[Music]
that are
well okay so there's a there's a there's
a question here right i mean as i said
nisk is not a mathematically
well-defined concept right and it could
be that you know you know
one could you know argue the view that
that once one has a nist speed up that
is just so you know solid that that no
one can question it that at that point
you just you are good enough that you
can either do an interactive protocol or
for that matter just a full fall power
mode of computation right you know i you
know that i i don't know if that's an
optimistic view or a pessimistic view
right
that's one of the reasons that it seemed
to me that
the employees have a very interesting
spot you know where
actually uh theory
yeah no absolutely
uh okay so i wanted to just briefly
mention you know so the other
intersections here okay so now you know
if you want sort of something in the
nisk era you know that is an np right
that you know clearly has efficient
verification there are you know all
these things that have been talked about
a lot over the last decade like the qaoa
which is quantum approximate
optimization algorithm uh which ed farhy
and his collaborators have been studying
um you know and which is a sort of like
a low depth
variant of the adiabatic algorithm so
it's a it's a heuristic algorithm for
trying to solve optimization problems
you know and its main early selling
point was that you could run it on a
nisk device right because of the low
depth you could just implement it and
see what happens there are now hundreds
and hundreds of papers you know
analyzing this algorithm and yet i would
say that none of them have sort of
clearly established a case where you
know we like we could say you know we
believe that it is going to beat a
classical you know classical
optimization methods you know in fact
there were uh um um you know there were
candidates for that that were then
refuted okay uh
where you know classical uh
approximation algorithms were found that
kid that can match or beat the
performance of qaoa okay so so i think
the best that we can say is that well
you know we can't rule out that there
will be some nisk speed up here you know
it is worth trying it to see right and i
would say something similar about you
know uh nisk uh algorithms for for
quantum machine learning problems
okay so uh okay and then if we just give
up on you know on nisk and we just say
uh
well you know assume a full fault
tolerant quantum computer with as many
millions of qubits as we want uh but you
know we want a an exponential speed up
we want it to be efficiently verifiable
then of course well there's shores
algorithm you know in all of its many
variations uh there are the interactive
protocols you know uh famously you know
that of uh mahadev uh uh subsequent work
uh building on that uh there is the new
breakthrough by uh yamakawa and janjari
which you're going to hear about very
shortly also i'll mention something
about it in in in this talk which gives
a actually a new uh uh uh
type of you know apparent exponential
quantum speed up okay and then there are
you know simulations of quantum physics
and chemistry okay so so here you know
there's you know
there's there's kind of a a a good
amount but but but we don't i wouldn't
say that we we really know how to do any
of this in the with with it with a
near-term device so basically we want to
get into the center of this diagram and
clearly you know there are three
different lines of attack that you can
envision right number one start with
these you know qaoa type you know these
sort of heuristic type of things you
know which is also what what you know
d-wave and what you know many other
quantum computing startups nowadays you
know what their entire business models
are based on right but uh you know try
to uh uh find something where where
where you're actually solidly beating a
classical computer you know in a fair
comparison
okay a second direction would be start
with you know the verifiable speed ups
that we're confident about and find some
way to shoehorn them into a nisk device
you know find some way you know if you
can even just reduce it from you know uh
thousands of qubits to hundreds of
qubits you know if you don't need some
full error correction but maybe some
error mitigation you know maybe you
could you know just barely get get such
a thing to to to work in the in in this
era okay and then the third approach
would be start with uh
you know the the kinds of quantum
supremacy experiments that have been
done that people are doing today
and then figure out a way to modify them
so that the results can be efficiently
checked with a classical computer
okay so all three of these approaches
are are are being tried by different
groups of people
um
uh i should say you know
another uh complication here is that
sometimes even when we have a speed up
that we're confident about it might only
be in the black box setting okay and so
there might be an oracle that we then
have to figure out can we instantiate it
by a real function you know in some way
that preserves the the the quantum speed
up okay so that's sort of yeah um
yet another axis here
all right so let me just say a little
bit you know briefly about these
different directions you know uh uh
from which you can try to uh approach
the center of this diagram
okay so you can start with uh uh
uh the sort of um um
um heuristic optimization methods and
then look for big speedups with them
okay and uh there was actually some very
exciting recent progress on this so so
the you know maybe the the earliest
quantum heuristic algorithm was the
adiabatic algorithm of you know far he
and his collaborators from the late 90s
uh you can think of it as sort of a a
potentially quantum enhanced version of
simulated annealing right uh
uh you know and and we knew you know
even from like 2002 or so that there are
you know you can construct fitness
landscapes where simulated annealing
will get stuck at some local optimum for
exponential time but the adiabatic
algorithm will reach the global minimum
in polynomial time by tunneling you know
out of the uh the the the local minimum
okay unfortunately you know for those
fitness landscapes once you knew what it
looked like there was a you know there's
a different classical algorithm that is
you know that is that you know that will
also find the global minimum quickly
right and so so i um
um you know for for
for for years and years i gave out the
problem can you show that there is a
black box pro you know
fitness landscape
where the adiabatic algorithm will just
provably beat any
classical algorithm you know in inquiry
complexity you know by a super
polynomial amount so that you know uh uh
during this pandemic has finally been
achieved uh first by matt hastings who
gave a an n versus end to the login uh
type of uh speed up and then gillian and
vasarani uh sharpened it to to an
exponential speed up okay uh however
this is that i took this diagram from
the uh gillian and vasarani paper uh it
is the it's for uh extremely bizarre you
know specially constructed uh fitness
landscapes that you know i would have no
idea how to realize them you know in the
non-black box world you know let alone
in any sort of practical problem let
alone in anything that we could fit onto
a nisk device okay but you know but
that's that's the the situation with the
adiabatic algorithm you know like you
can try it you know in the nisk era but
are you going to get a speed up you know
who knows right you you know you right
now it's you know the whole thing is is
uh is is is extremely empirical right
you just you know you've got to compare
against the best classical optimizers
and try to squint at it and see what
happens okay there's also you know
quantum you know even earlier than that
there were quantum walk algorithms where
again you you know for some very very
specially constructed graphs you can you
can get it so that a quantum walk will
reach a particular vertex in this case
the exit vertex of this graph
x provably exponentially faster than any
classical algorithm you know that can
only access this graph as a black box
okay but this is for very special graphs
in this case this is just two complete
binary trees that are connected by a
random cycle this is the the famous
example of childs at all from 20 years
ago and you know for more natural graphs
you know we have no idea like you know
will this phenomenon generalize right
will there you know will that will for
for sort of typical graphs will you get
anything more than a grover speed up you
know we you know we don't really know
and as i said for for qaoa you know even
even in the black box setting we don't
really have a candidate there for where
is it going to give an exponential speed
up
okay so that's that's the problem with
these things
um
okay so now approach number two uh was
to start with you know verifiable
quantum speedups uh and then somehow
make them nisk you know uh figure out
ways to implement them you know without
needing a full uh fault tolerant quantum
computer okay so you know of course you
know we can we could start here with the
whole family of algorithms that that
derives from shore's algorithm okay so
factoring you know discrete log uh all
sorts of problems involving a billion
groups such as elliptic curve groups you
know and then some very limited
generalizations to non-abelian groups
and you know i wish that i could you
know
uh um give you know approximate shortest
vector you know on this list uh but you
know we are you know we're still working
on that right or people are still
working on you know to what extent uh uh
can we solve lattice problems in in
quantum polynomial time and i'm sure
that we'll hear a lot more about that
this week
um but uh uh and then um you know the
the other big example here would be the
simulation of quantum physics and
chemistry uh
so um
uh you know hamiltonian simulations
simulating the rates of chemical
reactions um you know learning the uh
properties of the ground states of
various materials
um
so uh um okay so so my you know you know
basic feeling about it is that you know
uh absent some breakthrough you know uh
um all of this stuff seems to require
fault tolerance okay because uh you know
it all seems to require you know
representing you know numbers in binary
doing operations on them and
superposition like modular
exponentiation
um
you know and and you know you know we
really need some some new idea i think
to figure out how to do any of that in
the mascara
for quantum stimulation uh you know this
is maybe the best shot that we have
right of doing something in the nisk era
that is sort of actually you know useful
to someone and that you know not
unrelatedly is is verifiable okay uh uh
uh again in what sense you they excuse
me can you say again in what sense these
simulations are verifiable yes they're
verifiable because you can compare
against the actual molecule in nature
yeah exactly so for example if you're
trying to you know do a quantum
computation of the rate of a chemical
reaction you can measure against you
know the actual observed rate of that
reaction and you know see if you get the
chemical accuracy or whatever right so
you know so then even if the problem is
not an np you know in some sense you
know you can use nature as an oracle
right so um you know now unfortunately
you know i mean people have have
calculated in great detail over the last
five or six years uh the um you know
exactly what resources you know are you
going to need to do a
interesting quantum simulations using
the the known methods for for
hamiltonian simulation and so forth and
you know like it used to be you know
like you know formally polynomial but
just wildly impractical okay and today i
would say it's it's it's still
impractical but less wildly so right yes
there is
there's an issue there
you know
all right because you know there's
there's dynamics where the verifiability
would it's not clear how you verify it
versus finding ground states where you
get into
you know in terms of
approval
or something you know it's uh well well
you always need some observable that
you're that you're going to be measured
right you always need you know i mean i
mean you know you like you don't get
you know explicit access to the whole
wave function you know when you when you
put a simulation on the quantum computer
right so you always have to measure
something right that you know will tell
you something of interest whether it's
the you know the um you know magnetic
susceptibility of your material whether
it's the rate of the chemical reaction
right
now that
you know if you're looking for a ground
state yes then there are questions about
well
how do you actually find that
isn't that a heuristic then yeah yeah no
no so yeah so so so finding a ground
state in general is a qma complete
problem right and so we don't expect
that in the worst case even nature
itself could do that right uh and you
know now now in practice you know
typically ground states are easier to
find and they're easier to find not just
quantum leap but also classically right
so yeah you could say like like you know
what what i've been told at least by the
people who work on this is that it seems
like the better bet is to look at
dynamical problems right uh to look at
simulations of quantum dynamics such as
chemical reactions for example um and
and so you know uh estimates for example
from the group at microsoft have said
that you know with just you know um um a
hundred or 200 qubits you could already
start learning things about you know
some you know even like some
industrially relevant chemical reactions
like you know the ones that are used to
make fertilizer for example uh the
problem is that you know you need well
you know in i think in the the the 2016
uh estimate you know the the the circuit
depth was something like on the order of
a million okay so so it's only a hundred
qubits but you know they have to be
ridiculously good qubits and then and
that and that clearly is not yet uh
ready for for for the niskara and i
think that today people have managed to
get things down to like depths in the
thousands but it's still too high right
so
but you know but i think that if if we
are going to get something that we can
actually do in the nisk era you know
that you know without fault tolerance
where you know we will sort of see a
speed up and and can efficiently verify
you know and can verify that speed up in
a natural way then you know simulating
you know quantum dynamics is probably
the best bet that we that we know of
um
okay now we could try to take some
inspiration from the black box world you
know like we could look at simon's
problem for example uh um you know which
is you know finding this sort of hidden
shift yes is there a reference for
doing this kind of physical simulations
for which the depth is only on the order
of thousands um
let me say uh
look at the latest the stuff from the
microsoft group uh
yeah uh oh we can we can talk about it
all fine i i heard or email me i'll i'll
try to find that for you
okay so
um
you know we could we could so so you
know um interestingly simon's problem
you know we still don't know a concrete
instantiation for it like we still don't
know like an explicit hard instance
of simon's problem you know if we had
that that might be an example of
something that you know that would that
would lead to a more you know a nearer
term quantum speed up you know and this
has been an
open problem for almost 30 years i'm
still very interested in the answer to
that okay uh likewise the fluorescent
problem which i introduced in 2009 uh
with the goal of proving an oracle
separation between bqp and the
polynomial hierarchy okay i was not able
to do that that was finally achieved um
four years ago by a breakthrough of ron
roz and avi shaital uh so they they
showed that this problem you know you're
given two boolean functions you have to
decide whether one of them is correlated
with the fourier transform of the other
one right so this is a this problem is
in bqp you know but it is not in
np or even in ph right as as an oracle
problem in fact you know a ph machine
sort of cannot distinguish you know
these two like four-related uh boolean
functions from completely random
functions okay but then you know you
know now one could say could we find
some explicit instance of this problem
so are there any like
explicit functions that will be that
would be given to you by circuits
where you know one of them might be
close to the four-year transform of the
other one okay but other other than that
they look random right and where you
can't figure it out by just inspecting
the circuits
right but you could only figure it out
by running the
correlation algorithm on your quantum
computer right again you know if we had
that then that might you know you know i
mean it's a very it's an extremely
simple quantum algorithm so that you
know that that could lead to a a a nisk
speed up but but we know we just don't
know how to instantiate the oracle by uh
by a real problem that would give you
that
okay yeah so that's the problem
um now uh um just a couple of months ago
uh yamakawa and janjari uh had a
breakthrough uh they gave a completely
new uh exponential quantum speed up and
you're gonna hear uh uh
uh
much more about that in the next talk so
i won't you know uh belabor it but uh
basically they they study the following
problem
you know you are given uh let's say a
well a random or a pseudo random
function f
say mapping n bits to one bit and now
your task is to find a list of n bit
strings you know let's say uh x1 up to
xn such that first of all they all map
to zero under f okay now that by itself
is is trivial right you know half of all
the inputs mapped to zero so you just
you know pick a bunch of random ones
okay but then also when you take these n
strings and you concatenate them then
you get a string of n squared bits which
is a code word of a specific error
correcting code that you are given okay
uh
and so okay this is a you know
a strange looking problem but you know
what they show about it is that it does
have a polynomial time quantum algorithm
okay for an appropriate choice of the
error correcting code anyway uh you know
using the quantum fourier transform and
also convolution okay you're gonna uh uh
hear about it soon okay but they also
show that if f is just a random oracle
you know a random black box then any
classical algorithm that would find this
pre-image um needs exponentially many
queries to f
okay so
um um you know so and and and finally
you know we can notice that this problem
is an np search problem right so if you
find a solution if you find you know
these pre-images that concatenated give
you a code word it is easy to check it
right so it's an np search problem and
this is the first time that we've seen
an exponential quantum speed up for an
np search problem which only requires a
random oracle okay there's no structure
in the oracles that is necessary here
unfortunately there is still a lot of
structure needed in the quantum
algorithm okay the quantum algorithm
basically has to do a bunch of decoding
of an error correcting code you know on
superpositions of of of uh uh uh of of
inputs you know they you know which end
up being lattice computations actually
yes great so
just a small question just clarify yeah
np search problem is identical
synonymous to fnp
uh yeah
yes and yeah yes
thank you yeah yeah it means a search
problem where you can you know
efficiently verify an answer to it well
sure but yeah yeah
but you know yeah the important point
here is not
not the decision the decision problem is
trivial the answer is always yes
to you know to is there a solution the
problem is to find the solution
so so it's actually a tfm right
so the code is chosen so that the answer
is
yeah or at least it's yes with
overwhelming probability over
well we don't we don't know how to do
that and in fact the errands and
unbiased conjecture would say that you
can't
i'll i'll have that on and i'll slater
slide but who's wrong if you just say
look you know
for the following
yes is there a solution with the
following creature
uh well because then it's not the same
problem anymore it's just this is not
this you know you know if we if you look
at their algorithm it will generate a
random solution it's not going to
generate a solution with this specific
prefix
okay
so yeah so so so although they
eliminated all the structure from the
oracle the algorithm still looks kind of
shore like it still looks like something
that we would have no idea how to
implement in the in your term er
okay so then approach number three would
be well start with you know these
sampling based quantum supremacy
experiments such as boson sampling which
archipov and i introduced 11 years ago
and which has now been uh um
demonstrated by the team at uh ustc in
china with about a hundred photons and
actually you know there's a there's a
new paper by byzanto where they're you
know i still have to to read it and see
how much i you know uh uh uh you know uh
try to try to evaluate that okay but uh
uh um
you know then and then you know the
first quantum supremacy experiments were
the ones from from google uh from late
2019 uh ustc has since also done a
random circuit sampling with um you know
2d grids of superconducting qubits this
is what it looks like this is the
dilution fridge uh as i said the problem
with all these things is that it takes
exponential time to verify the results
with a classical computer for example if
you use this linear cross-entropy
benchmark
okay so i think an enormous challenge is
to figure out how to take these
near-term quantum supremacy experiments
based on sampling problems and make them
verifiable make them efficiently
verifiable okay as i said you know there
are these very elegant protocols uh of
of mahadev and then you know there's a a
sort of a more efficient version by you
know kahana moku meyer at all uh uh for
well for four specifically for quantum
supremacy right but uh um
uh uh you know these these these all all
of these protocols for sort of verifying
a quantum computation sort of require
evaluating a trapdoor function on
superpositions of inputs which is sort
of you know which is again is is kind of
going to be a stumbling block uh in in
in this era
uh so now a cruder idea would be uh well
well you know why can't we just take the
you know
random circuit sampling type of
experiments and modify them you know so
you know to insert some kind of secret
that you know uh uh if you're just
looking at the circuit you won't know
but someone who uh uh you know uh you
know the person who generated the
circuit will know this secret and and
they'll be able to recognize the secret
in the outputs that are sampled from
that circuit
okay so so so what i would like is some
protocol where a challenger creates a
quantum circuit c that looks random but
it conceals some secret string s let's
say such that you know we at least we
believe that you can only find s
efficiently by running c on a quantum
computer
right
and okay now the question is how do we
implement this this this this very
simple idea you know there was a very
bold proposal you know very early by
bremner and shepard in 2008 uh but that
was actually uh
you know using some some exotic error
correcting codes uh and their proposal
was killed a few years ago by kahanamoku
meyer he gave a a classical uh method
for spoofing it greg you had a question
is this why
there is
so the the advantage of shora's
algorithm yeah
there is a separation yeah whereas i
don't know of any such theorems for this
yeah that that that i mean i mean of
course we would like we will eagerly
accept any theorems that we can get okay
but that might not be yeah that might be
too much to hope for because when we get
the theorems usually they are relative
to an oracle
usually they involve a black box i
are they they're going to have to
because
okay all right additional theorems are
okay okay my question is yeah
is
you're looking for
uh
missed and verifiable or yes
yeah okay
is is there any suggestion for
disc
and
verifiable
and
there is a conditional theorem
for the advantage
uh that's exactly what i'm asking for in
this slide this is this slide
yeah that yes i'm asking for that okay
i'm asking for that
all right
i'm asking you get get
do as much as you can in that direction
yeah all three yeah
so yeah i i even i i literally had a
slide with you know the enter you know
you came after this this is what i want
okay
so
um
so yeah so we so we thought a lot about
you know whether you can do this with
boson sampling uh whether you can design
a linear optical network that will
somehow you know look like just a random
sequence of beam splitters but that will
secretly concentrate most of the
amplitude onto a single output state and
uh uh hoywen and i were able to get a
no-go theorem saying that well if if if
you define the goal that strongly then
basically you can't do that with with
boson sampling okay if you try to do it
you're go it's going to you know in
boson sampling the amplitudes uh are are
permanents of various sub matrices of
your unitary matrix
um
but if i try to concentrate a whole lot
of amplitude on a single output then
then you know you know it's permanent
well the permanent of that sub matrix
will have to be very very large and that
will cause that matrix that sub matrix
to sort of stick out like a sore thumb
it'll have to be like the identity
matrix or something you know similar to
it so that you could just identify you
know easily find it classically okay
that doesn't rule out that maybe there
is some way to get uh um um you know
such a protocol with boson sampling but
it would have to involve exponentially
many different outputs rather than only
one of them
okay so let me um you know i'm i'm
running out of time but i want to give
you a as far as i know a new open
question which i think is is sort of
directly relevant to uh to this quest to
design a sort of uh uh uh
um you know to sort of
take these you know random circuit
sampling uh quantum supremacy
experiments and make them verifiable all
right so so given a quantum circuit c
let me call it peaked if uh well you
know really what i want to say is just
if there is something about the you know
it's it's output when you measure that
you can easily recognize and easily tell
apart from random okay but just to be
concrete let me say if there is some
basis state x that is observed with pr
with at least 10 probability when you
when you make a measurement at the end
okay so you know most if i pick a
quantum circuit at random with
overwhelming probability it will not be
peaked right almost all of the outputs
will have probability you know on the
order of two to the minus n you know
times various constants okay and so this
is only some very special quantum
circuits that are like this okay so now
the question i ask is suppose that i
pick a random
quantum circuit with say n qubits and n
squared gates but i pick it uniformly at
random from only among the peak circuits
okay then what does such a circuit look
like
okay now uh you know one you know one
could imagine a boring possibility maybe
what it looks like you know i mean one
one simple way to get a peak circuit is
you just apply a whole bunch of random
gates and then you apply the inverse of
what you just did right you just you
know reverse everything to get back to
the all zero state
right uh uh so so maybe you know random
a random peak circuit just looks like a
bunch of gates
along with their inverses right and then
you would just start canceling them out
and you would trivially see that you
know that that the circuit does does
does does nearly nothing
okay uh but
another possibility is that it would
look obfuscated so you know it would
look to you just like it was a random
circuit okay and yet you know only by
running it on a quantum computer would
you see that it actually you know is not
random it actually sort of
creates this interference pattern that
that gives a particular output you know
state a large probability okay so so
which
which which situation is it
uh you know and so so a closely related
question would be yeah
easier to answer if you strengthen the
first requirement to be just one instead
of point one like it's literally
outputting a classical basis oh that
might be that might well be serious yeah
i mean i mean but then then it also
might depend heavily on the geez
yeah
yeah so okay so a closely related
question would be i give you an m gate
random circuit you know uh uh now how
many more gates do you need to tack on
to the end of it in order to get a peak
circuit okay so you know from recent
results on t designs we can show that
the answer must be at least
m to some power like it must be at least
m to the one tenth power or something
like that right uh from from like
results of brandow and harrow and so
forth about you know random circuits
giving you t designs okay we also know
that the answer is at most m
why because well you could always just
invert the circuit right and you know
right just like this and get back to a
peak circuit okay but it actually
matters a lot where we are between these
two okay like you know if there's any
improvement over m right then this says
that the output of a random circuit
actually has some kind of you know
pattern that you can you can
non-trivially access right and and if
you could then just genera you know
figure out how to generate that then
that would give you a candidate for a
nist quantum supremacy experiment okay
you know it would it would you would say
you know apply this random circuit and
then tack this extra stuff on the end of
it that tells you know that that makes
it peaked right and then you know
um
so yeah so you know or more generally we
could ask
is there a fast way to sample peak
circuits you know in in such a way that
they are polynomial time
indistinguishable from random quantum
circuits
okay and sort of you could say any such
way will would constitute a candidate
for nist quantum supremacy experiments
right it'll be nisk because the circuits
look random you know it will be
verifiable because the circuits will be
peaked
okay
so you know so i would i would like to
know you know whether this is possible
or not
sorry i'm missing something because you
could just run it four times and
distinguish by the oh yeah yeah yeah i
mean polynomial time classically in
distinction oh okay okay okay
yeah yeah that's that that's the entire
point here right
so yeah so you know one can also think
about this in a michael nielsen sort of
geometric framework for uh circuit
complexity where you will you think of a
quantum circuit as like a geodesic you
know in some manifold and you know what
a peak circuit corresponds to is it's
some kind of short path which start you
know starts at a computational basis
state wanders around in this you know
huge space this you know s u of two to
the n and then ends up you know close to
another computational basis state
and then you know the question becomes
sort of how do we find paths
short paths so polynomial size circuits
but that are exponentially hard to sort
of contract to trivial paths which sort
of would never leave the computational
basis right it's a you know you know it
has a topology where every path can be
contracted but we want a path that would
be exponentially hard to see that it can
be contracted right yeah so you sort of
wander out into the vastness of hilbert
face and then you come back to the
computational basis right but in some
way that is more interesting then you
just go out and then you just turn
around and return exactly the way you
started right you want to sort of go
around some some roundabout way where
it's hard for a classical computer to
see what's going on
okay so i had a whole second part about
the you know black box quantum speedups
which i'm going to in the collision
problem and so forth which i'm going to
skip because i'm out of time
um
you know and then sort of a hierarchy of
structure and black box problems and
then this errands and unbianus
conjecture which is related to what
umesh asked about before the erinson
unbianus conjecture basically says that
for decision problems there should be no
exponential quantum speedups relative to
a random oracle okay and there's been
some very exciting recent progress
toward proving that conjecture by bansal
sinha and ronald the wolf
um
and um you know and we sort of
interpreted this as sort of saying well
relative to a random oracle you know you
can only ever get a grover type of
quantum speed up right and not an
exponential one but that in turn you
know that interpretation is too strong
as we now know from yamakawa and gentry
okay uh which you're going to hear about
very soon so i think this is deep in the
mystery of the role of structure in
quantum speedups by saying that you know
you can remove all the structure from
the oracle for an np search problem um
you know by putting the structure into
the algorithm so my concluding thought
is there a law of conservation of
weirdness that you know for every
exponential quantum speed up there must
be some weirdness in the problem
statement that you exploit to focus
amplitude on the rare right answers how
how how how small can we squeeze that
weirdness and can we squeeze it into a
nisk device so that was that was all so
thank you
the status of the conjecture with
respect to the new result yeah yeah yes
so that was just sorry what i was trying
to say before but uh uh so the okay so
so the key point is this the the
aaronson bionis conjecture as far as we
know is still true okay in fact you know
it's even can you know
assumed in this yamakawa gentry paper to
prove one of their subsidiary results
okay the key point is that this
conjecture is for decision problems
right yamakawa and dandry are studying
an np search problem right so it's just
not covered by this theorem
all right
so you know you might think that
difference between decision and search
problems is not that big a deal just you
know you know we're now learning that
it's a huge deal
um
would you still consider it to be
verifiable if the circuit is
well you know i mean that that would
still be interesting like it's even
interesting if you just need brute force
if you need exponential time to generate
the circuit right that that that's
already interesting to me as an al
already i don't know how to do it okay
but you know now if if you you know if
you could do it with a quantum computer
so much the better but then you know we
would still have work to do to get
something practical you know that we can
do it right to do something in the niska
or i want a classical girl to generate
the circuit
great so
you know we'll take a break until the
next talk at 10 30.